Tố hệ đam ăn nhe là sai
Mọi thật luôn thì bảo ở đây, mình của bệ dây món, nhưng mà các bạn gặp mình tô
Mấy là mấy đàn bệ dây, nha
Cái trời bài khó lâu bài này là bài dưới thiệu
Chuyện nhỉ? Họ vẫn thấy trả tình không ở đây là đúng là
Đúng là
Để đã cắt thủ xuống ở đây cho các bạn
Để thử ra nó mình quán ngường đúng không?
Nào, cùng đi này, xeo tô chạy lý tục không nghĩ, giống lần
Chỉ dừng lại mời phút tạc, mình xe để nó, là đến xeo dừng lại mời phút
Đi lấy quá, đi lấy với khút
Họ sẽ 2 thôi, bây giờ đó họ là ý tính khoảng thời gian truyền đâu
Và khoan đường đi được của các hành khách
Thì lên xanh, đúng không?
Hãy thích lên xanh, đi từ ra đi bây, hãy đi bây giờ
Bởi vậy, đúng là, thế lòng thiệt là, khoan đường có đường thì xe quá
Túng không?
Quang đường mà không đoạn cho là được là
Quang đường mà nhau, quang đường mà nhau, một trong mình gâm đối với ra cho mà
Túng không?
Nhưng mà thích khoảng lựa ý từ ra đi bây, khoảng hành khách ngày là một trong 5 rồi
Được rồi, mình mẹ là thời gian nữa, hãy có thể có dôn mà thôi, thì có thể tính cái ngày
Thì không giữ nó thấy đây, mình thích tính luôn, thời gian từ ra khách
Đúng không? Để mà chúng ta tính cho thông phút rồi, ngồi nha
Là thì sao nó thì tạm có nằm bười đúng không?
Thế, tổng cộp cho nó chuy chuyện, nó cho là 2 tiếng nằm mê phút
Nhưng mà ông nào khoan cho 1 2 tiếng nằm phút là 2, bị sao?
Đi mình đi là 1 1 tiếng nằm phút mình đúng không?
Nha thực tế thì ra 2 tiếng chuyện của ta
Thế tất cả, nó có thể khoảng lựa rắn chuyện đâu, mà
Đúng không? Khung cẩy từ răng ý, vậy cho thì nó thì khoảng lựa rắn chuyện, nó có thể khoảng lựa
Thì thì nó có thể khoảng lựa bây giờ, thôi, hãy ra 2 tiếng khách
Thế thôi
Chúng không? Chúng không?
Chào tất cả, nhìn thấy hạm nó sẽ tâm tính hạ bàn phút rồi
Cô em nào?
Ở nhà, em quen mất là gì?
Giết thỏa tử gán chuyển lợp nối
Nên bê, á đến xe lúc phải giả mấy lâm
Nhìn mất mời phút
Bài giả hai lâm mưa xúc hát
Tụi wow, chỉ tảm đợi lâm mưa với là bán dấu
Một lời hai lâm phút thì có người là nha
Bài bí dơ nè, có trục tố nè
Phần lâu kinh của thời thành định nhận thêm các tài điện và bài giáng hành nè